yeah walk to this video a bit later ten
seconds lost some other window but good
obstructed to the howitzer it's fixed
yeah let's see I'm playing a five-minute
game against armor gr from the US
playing the Berlin and the rule of pest
but it's going for a quick Queenie to I
think you still can't play Bishop c5
p.m. alright so hmm yeah probably
castles he will probably play just with
d3 not go for any default business so
probably be three now I try not to play
d6 too early maybe I get nd5 in one I
don't want Bishop g5 so this is why I
played age six and maybe now d 5 yeah
why not rubbing space know that I was
briefly thinking maybe I should have
played a six but it's not really really
helping him now that's surprising I
didn't expect him to take relief this
looks like it should be really nice for
Black Knight therefore even here and I
Bishop g4 was also fine ok Bishop g5
might play age three and
it's still good yeah I have night f form
which jon is very irritating for what
yeah well he's ignoring a lot of miles
just playing quick replies this was the
the essential threat because why the
Queen cannot really move to to see to
for instance as I will capture f3 it if
he takes pawn takes the queerness attack
that needs to go to a somewhat
unfortunate square like let's say C 2
and then I can still take and play Queen
d5 to attack the pawn and it's hard to
cover it's especially bad with the rukon
d1 yeah so I thought he he needs to take
it now I cannot even recapture because
of community 5 s's check mate check made
on g2 white resins jump this was an
currently quick win with Abaddon defense
of the room but he really did did help
me much I mean starting with e takes d5
this already seems quite comfortable for
black not yeah not a decisive thing but
it's certainly nice for our for me but
rock d 1 is really a bad one should
should give me a good game nida form
takes yeah yeah well okay he needs tubes
what deck doing this all wrong yeah this
was was just just losing me to take him
and then move it let's say here and this
position is certainly okay for me but
not win he's a tackling this poem so I
am must be
I must be playing a with with good
timing let's say I take and yeah Jim now
this is okay and it's not that too
brilliant maybe what he played wasn't so
bad after all I mean not not that it's
helping him but it seems to not lead to
two big problems I he plays correctly or
did he absolutely needs to take after
this takes yeah he can take care but
then I just go grab this one and I'm
look up who will rock two and one and so
in the in the game at what the checkmate
fell not much of a dance but unusually
quick win yeah I don't really think that
it takes two fibers so great he needs to
play on cam can you play something else
not so easy actually that you need to
also think about deform yeah it's not a
real idea at the moment but it might be
later yeah anyways the Berlin is a fine
line and the sidelines don't really a
promise much alright thanks for watching